liebe kolleginnen und kollegen herzlich
willkommen in der bundespressekonferenz
an diesem montag nach einer wahl hamburg
hat eine neue bürgerschaft gewählt das
endgültige amtliche ergebnis liegt uns
noch nicht vor dennoch haben wir heute
verschiedene parteien zu gast wir uns
das ergebnis aus ihrer perspektive
einordnen den auftakt macht heute die
afd
dazu sind bei uns zu gast ich gehe jetzt
von von meiner rechten nach links der
bundessprecher kinogruppe daneben in
vertretung von erkrankten herrn 9a
fdp-fraktionssprecher alexander gauland
daneben den fdp fraktionsvorsitzenden
der bürgerschaft in hamburg
alexander wolf und in gleicher funktion
dirk böckermann willkommen und hair
group ag hat als erster das wort ja auch
von meiner seite mit morgen herzlich
willkommen hier bundespressekonferenz
sie alle begrüßen
zu den gestrigen wahlergebnis in hamburg
was wir heute hier auswerten wollen oder
auch gesprächen wollen muss ich sagen
bin ich erst partei wurde zwar erst mal
sehr zufrieden dass wir dieses ergebnis
einfahren konnten
dass wir noch die unsere leistung über
die fünf-prozent-hürde erreichen konnten
dass wir sicher eingezogen sind ich
möchte mich als erstes aber auch bei den
wählerinnen und wählern in hamburg
bedanken aber natürlich vor allem bei
unseren beiden spitzenkandidaten herrn
ackermann und wolf die wird einen
hervorragenden wahlkampf geleistet haben
einen sehr engagierten wahlkampf unter
wirklich schwierigen bedingungen auch
diese dann sicherlich noch eingehen
werden damit die mich recht hat zu
bedanken
die fdp bleibt in allen
landesparlamenten weiterhin erhalten
wir sind weiter eine etablierte partei
an elite kraft und haben das in hamburg
auch gestern bestätigt wenngleich wie
gesagt die voraussetzungen sicherlich
schwierig waren
das zu meiner ja ich das wort gibt es
nicht viel zu ergänzen
der kubaner hat eigentlich alles gesagt
ich will nur noch mal darauf hinweisen
er hat zu recht gesagt
schwierig schwierig war es auch deshalb
weil wir in einer weise in den letzten
tagen ja wochen kann man schon sagen
ausgegrenzt worden sind und gegen uns ja
geradezu eine hetze betrieben worden ist
wie ich das ehrlich gesagt noch nicht
erlebt habe und auch der bundesrepublik
nicht für möglich gehalten habe das
bezieht sich auch auf kommentare großer
leitmedien bei denen uns im grunde
genommen etwas unterstellt wird was in
keiner weise auf eine demokratische
partei zutrifft und ich gebe offen zu
dieser art der auseinandersetzung macht
mir sorge wenn wir da nicht alle
abrüsten dann ist die demokratie
wirklich gefährdet aber nicht durch uns
sondern durch versuche uns aus einem
demokratischen spektrum auszugrenzen
vielleicht so viel zu beginn dann ist
jetzt zunächst ein dokument ich dachte
wir hatten die reihenfolge vereinbart
aber dazu erst herr dokument dann herr
wolf werden damen und herren das war
gestern ein spannender tag und das ist
heute ein schöner tag
wir sind mit 5,3 prozent in die
hamburgische bürgerschaft eingezogen
obwohl es in hamburg so etwas wie eine
maximale ausgrenzung der ard gegeben hat
ich habe solche umstände auch noch nie
erlebt ich saß bereits von 2001 bis 2004
in der hamburgischen bürgerschaft damals
mit ronald schill gemeinsam und was wir
hier jetzt in den letzten tagen
insbesondere erlebt haben dass wir als
nazis und als faschisten bezeichnet
worden sind das ist schon wirklich ein
unglaublicher vorgang
wie gesagt das maximum an ja wenn ich
das sagen an ausgrenzung und angesichts
der umstände dass hier in hamburg keine
einzige politische veranstaltung
durchführen konnten weil die wirte von
der antifa massiv unter druck gesetzt
worden sind
angesichts der tatsache auch dass all
unsere wahlplakate regelmäßig zerstört
worden sind dass sie uns auch einklagen
mussten in öffentliche bürgerhäuser
angesichts all dieser tatsachen ist das
ergebnis von 5,3 prozent für uns ein
wirklich schönes ergebnis
wir lagen in den wochen und monaten
vorher stabil bei sieben prozent in den
umfragen und in den letzten 14 tagen
ging es dann massiv bergab 12 prozent
jeder kann sich vielleicht vorstellen
woran das gelegen hat
es ist auch von von kollegen von ihnen
auf deren privaten facebook seiten
beispielsweise veröffentlicht worden
werft oder jagt die hetzer aus dem
rathaus da können sie mal sehen welche
verrohung der sprache in hamburg
stattgefunden hat ich kann es auch
jederzeit gerne belegen so weit erst
noch von meiner seite auch von meiner
seite erst mal schönes guten morgen wir
haben unter äußerst schwierigen
umständen unsere stimmenanzahl praktisch
gehalten
wir hatten vor fünf jahren 214.000
stimmen und wir haben derzeit und dass
es noch nicht die schluss zahl 211.000
stimmen das ist im grunde genau das
gleiche ergebnis dass wir relativ statt
61 bei 53 jetzt gelandet sind liegt an
der um sieben prozent gestiegenen
wahlbeteiligung damals 56 prozent jetzt
63 prozent da ist spielt auch eine rolle
darin dass bei den jungwählern die
wahlbeteiligung besonders hoch ist bei
denen die grünen die mit abstand
stärkste partei geworden sind deutlich
vor der spd
wir nicht so stark abgeschnitten haben
wir über die schwierigen umstände des
wahlkampfs haben wir bereits gesprochen
wir hatten selbst die wahlkampf
schlussveranstaltung nicht in hamburg
durchführen können sondern mussten
ausweichen auf das benachbarte schleswig
holstein auf henstedt ulzburg bei den
hamburg die wirte der hut und
druck gesetzt werden von einer antifa
szene von einer militanten antifa szene
die die wirte anschreibt und nicht nur
die scheiben und die lokalitäten und die
räume gefährdet sondern die die wirte an
schreibt mit worten wie wir wissen wo
ihre kinder zur schule gehen
es gab mehrere anschläge auf mehrere
kandidaten in der im wahlkampf nicht
zuletzt auf der knoke manns wohnadresse
das ganze gefördert gepampert sage ich
jetzt mal von einem rot grünen senat der
auf dem linken auge blind ist der nach
g20 keinerlei konsequenzen gezogen hat
und stattdessen einen popanz von wegen
rechter bedrohung an die wand malt und
in einer unzulässigen unfairen und
unverschämten diffamierung afd und
rechten rechtsaußen terrorismus in einer
art und weise in einem atemzug zusammen
zu bringen versucht dass man sich als
demokrat wir als rechtsstaatspartei nur
dagegen verwahren können vielleicht noch
ein satz dazu was besonders dramatisch
durchaus ist ist das sind die verluste
der bürgerlichen parteien insgesamt bei
uns noch relativ maß voll
wenn man die denn den den aufgrund der
höheren wahlbeteiligung die den den
prozentsatz von 5,3 zu 6,1 in bezug
setzt dann ist das ein rückgang um 13
prozent bei der fdp ist der rückgang
relativ bei 32 prozent bei der cdu 25
prozent und dass diese drei bürgerlichen
parteien zusammen in einer stadt wie
hamburg bei unter 25 prozent rauskommen
bürgerlichen parteien weniger als ein
viertel des elektro rats repräsentieren
das allerdings gibt mir schon zu denken
und sollte ein warnsignal auch sein für
unsere demokratie
ich habe mich gefragt ob am ende
angesichts des einzugs der asc das
vielleicht als spaßige bemerkung am
schluss über unsere demokratie unter
angela merkel
ob angela merkel diesmal wieder aus
pretoria oder aus einem hammer auf
dieser welt sich meldet die wahl müsse
korrigiert werden mit dem wiedereinzug
der fdp ein unverzeihliches ergebnis
herausgekommen das erste mal von meiner
seite zum einstieg dann kommen wir zu
ihren fragen ich habe schon mehrere
fragen ja dem fette wenn sie dazu sagen
an wen sich die frage richtet ist das
sicherlich hilfreich und herr wehner
macht den anfang
meine frage geht einem herrn grube halle
und vielleicht auch noch an herrn
gauland beantworten will
herr grupp haller sie haben wie auch
fast alle führenden fdp- politiker die
morde von hanau zunächst als tat eines
geisteskranken bezeichnet und auch die
anderen art die politiker haben von
einem wahnsinnigen oder einem
geistesgestörten gesprochen und haben
sie gestern in einem brief zusammen mit
erneuten an die ard mitglieder von einem
rassistischen verbrechen geschrieben
dessen motiv ausländer hass war möchte
sie fragen wie kommt es zu diesem
sinneswandel
zunächst einmal ist es kein sinneswandel
zu den informationen die wir kurz nach
der tat hatten konnte man nur wirklich
davon ausgehen dass es sich um einen
geisteskranken oder einen wahnsinnigen
in diesem bezug handelt das bestätigen
mittlerweile selbst ärzte das muss man
ganz klar sagen es ist in dieser form
der mann jetzt sie sich das manifest
dieses täters dieses einzeltäters
derzeitigen einzeltäters ansieht muss
man davon ausgehen dass es einen
rassistischen hintergrund hatte das ist
muss man klar benennen und das tue ich
in diesem sinne auch zu der damaligen
zeit zu den damaligen informationen die
uns die mir damals vorlagen konnte ich
noch nicht davon ausgehen wie weit sich
das ergeben hat wir sollten auch
weiterhin die ermittlungsergebnisse
abwarten die immer noch recht dünn sind
die ermittlungsbehörden
haben noch viel arbeit vor sich das
sollten wir respektieren und natürlich
erstmal abwarten
warum alle anderen parteien diesen
rassistischen hintergrund ich sofort
erkannt nur die afg hat ihn nicht
erkannt
ich würde nicht sagen dass wir das nicht
erkannt haben ich denke in dieser in
diesem moment dieses schrecklichen
anschlags möglich zehn menschen auf
grauenvolle art und weise ums leben
gekommen was uns alle geschockt hat auch
mich geschockt hat auf unsere partei
geschockt hat gebetet eigentlich erstmal
in ruhe auch zu trauern auf trauern sie
dürfen auch das darf die ard auch das
darf ich das will ich ganz klar betonen
wenn wir diese schreckliche tat zum
beispiel in ording betrachtet mit diesen
ähnlichen anschlag von anders breivik
was dort geschehen ist wie sich
parteiübergreifend dort in norwegen eine
trauer ausgebildet hat bzw auch gedacht
getraut werden durfte und konnte ohne
sofortige schuldzuweisungen an einer
oppositionspartei oder eine rechte
partei oder eine linke partei dann halte
ich das für auch für unser land geboten
hätten sich meiner meinung nach gehört
dass man auch diese tat erst mal in
trauer zur kenntnis nimmt und dann
weitere schritte abwartet bzw
ermittlungsergebnisse abwarten
vielleicht noch ein satz dazu auch ein
krankes gehirn kann eine rassistische
motivation in seinem kranken gehören
haben das steht auch in dem brief ganz
deutlich drin ich sehe also überhaupt
kein widerspruch zu ergänzen
nur ein satz dazu die anderen parteien
haben da nicht etwas früher erkannt
sondern die haben in einer aus meiner
sicht schamlosen weise sofort das ganze
versucht zu instrumentalisieren und zu
missbrauchen
zu einer hetze gegen die afd bei der man
sich fragt wie weit sind wir eigentlich
gekommen eine derart maßlose hetze
gerade in den letzten 48 stunden vor dem
wahltag die ist glaube ich einzigartig
in diesem sommer
herr nooke man möchte dazu haben wir es
mal ganz klar und deutlich zu sagen
diese rechtsextremistischen
terrorattacken die haben überhaupt aber
auch gar nichts mit der fdp zu tun bin
ja schon ein bisschen älter
ich habe die brandanschläge von solingen
miterlebt damals gab es keine afd
ich habe das miterlebt was die nsu
gemacht haben damals gab es keine afd
und es gab diverse attentate
beispielsweise olympia attentat auch das
war rechtsradikaler
rechtsextremistischer terror auch damals
gab es keine afg also man sollte bitte
nicht so tun als würde dieser
rechtsextremistische terrier irgendwo
ursache in der hfg haben und da bin ich
auch ganz klar mal abzurüsten wie gesagt
wir haben nichts mit rechtsextremismus
zu tun
wir haben in hamburg und soweit ich
weiss auch im bund permanent darauf
hingewiesen dass hier jede art von
extremismus und schon gewalt ablehnen
egal ob das linksextremismus
rechtsextremismus oder religiös bedingte
extremistisch die nächste frage hat frau
käßmann ich wüsste gerne von den
hamburger wahlkämpfern ob sie sicher
sein können dass ihnen diese behinderung
die sie geschildert haben nur geschadet
haben es wäre ja auch denkbar dass es da
so einen solidarisierungseffekt gibt und
dann wüsste ich gerne von herrn dr
bauland oder von herrn gruppe was denn
das rezept der afg gegen
rechtsextremismus ist vielleicht ist da
eine schwäche der partei gesehen worden
die auch im hamburger wahlkampf
geschadet hat denn andere parteien haben
das ja ausführlich diskutiert auch
unabhängig von der frage wie die
motivation des attentäters gewesen war
in hanau ist es gab ja vorher die
festnahme der gruppe um werner es gab
die die attacke auf die synagoge in
halle und es gab den mord an herrn übte
vielleicht wird der afd
in diesem feld nicht genug kompetenz
zugetraut
also natürlich natürlich hat es uns
geschadet dass die antifa beispielsweise
unsere stände in hamburg permanent
umringt
mit transparenten abgeschottet hat so
dass die bürger kaum an unserem menschen
andere mitglieder herangekommen sind
natürlich schadet es wenn man permanent
von allen parteien
und wenn man das gesamte politische und
mediale establishment hamburg hatte sich
gegen uns muss man sagen verschworen
geradezu und überall gab es diese gucken
skeptisch aber überall gab es diese
sprüche räumt die hetze aus dem
hamburger rathaus das ging sogar so weit
dass die stellvertretende
bürgermeisterin in hamburg gemeinsam auf
demonstrationen aufgetreten ist mit der
interventionistischen linken die also
maßgebliche initiatoren der hamburger
unruhen beim g-20 gewesen sie das kann
ich sagen war damals mitglied als ob man
dort im ausschuss und natürlich schade
dass uns wenn auch die medien einseitig
in dieses horn blasen wohl wissen dass
gerade die hamburger fdp sich in der
vergangenheit einen gewissen ruf
erarbeitet hat und zwar dafür ein
relativ hanseatischer und liberaler
landesverband sind und uns dann
sozusagen der arten derart zu
stigmatisieren
glauben sie nicht dass es irgendjemandem
nutzt von uns jedenfalls nicht wir haben
allerdings auch in der tat im nachhinein
erfahren dass der ein oder andere wähler
die uns angeschrieben hat deutlich
gemacht hat dass gerade diese
stigmatisierung ihm ganz übel
aufgestoßen ist und dass dann doch noch
leute zur wahl gegangen sind obwohl sie
am anfang gesagt haben wir gehen da
nicht zur wahl aber diese einseitige
massive benachteiligung weckt natürlich
auch das gerechtigkeitsgefühl bestimmte
hamburger bürger schichten um das noch
ganz kurz zu ergänzen
sie spielen ja auf dieses narrativ an
afd begeben sich geradezu gerne in eine
opferrolle
nein wir begeben uns nicht gerne in
einer opferrolle es nicht ich meinte
jetzt einfach wie das beim wähler
ankommt kann ich auch war meine dann
sage ich obwohl es schwingt meist mit es
ist ja ein gewisses fremming damit auch
verbunden mit dem wiederholten wort
gebraucht aus meiner sicht schadet es
massiv sowohl unsere entfaltung im
wahlkampf wo wir an bürger weniger
herantreten können
wenn die stände attackiert werden
mehrfach geschehen als einzige von allen
parteien wie wir mit einer skr fragt
haben wenn die plakate zerstört werden
wenn wir keine räumlichkeiten bei wirten
bekommen und natürlich ist es eine
schwelle bei bürgern die nicht unsere
stammwähler ist aber die wir auch
erreichen und ansprechen wollen wenn die
kontakt mit uns vermieden wird und b in
suggeriert wird dass sie irgendetwas
böses rechtes mit dem man möglichst
politik nichts zu tun haben sollte
erstmalig kann ein ganz kurzes noch
ergänzen
ich will mal was grundsätzliches sagen
also rechtsextremismus muss mit
rechtsstaatlichen mitteln bekämpft
werden in der fdp gibt es kein
rechtsextremismus jetzt will ich ganz
klar sagen und für uns und auch was den
brief noch mal angeht auch noch mal
wichtig gewesen auch darauf hinzuweisen
in welchen gesellschaftlichen klima wir
mittlerweile hier leben und da haben
alle parteien ihren anteil daran
diese situation so aufgeheizt zu haben
auch die mit auch teile der medien will
ich doch nicht ausnehmen das haben wir
wie gesagt im vorfeld in dieser hamburg
wahl massiv erlebt und diese
selbstreflexion die wir angestoßen haben
die wir mit diesem brief anstoßen
wollten die natürlich in eine debatte
auslösen wird auch innerparteilich ganz
klar das gebietet sich aber meiner
meinung nach auch für andere parteien
die uns pauschal als faschisten als
nazis permanent bezeichnen die
mittlerweile nicht davor zurückschrecken
uns auch oder auch aufrufe zu gewalt
medial auch zu äußern was sie von
fdp-politiker noch nie gehört haben dass
es aufrufe zu gewalt gehabt das will man
auch mal ganz klar sagen und da fragt
man sich ganz ehrlich wo soll das
eigentlich noch hinführen wie sie
gedanken mache ich mir mache ich mir
auch aus sorge aus sorge über hoch
unsere vielen kommunalpolitiker die wir
haben die an ständen angegriffen werden
soll es tote geben in diesem bereich
noch mehr verletzte häuser werden
beschmiert familien wenn wir von mir
diskreditiert man traut sich nicht mehr
die meinung zu sagen das erleben wir
doch in diesem land aktuell
und darauf möchten wir aufmerksam machen
das noch hinführen diese abrüstung grad
der bezeichnung in bücher auch im
bundestag erleben wo wir vor zwei jahren
eingezogen sind 2017
da waren auch die das größte schimpfwort
rechtspopulist mittlerweile wird unisono
mittlerweile auch von politikern der cdu
wenn wir als faschisten und nazis
bezeichnet ohne dass der
bundestagspräsident dort mittlerweile
ordnungsrufe vergibt auch da ist eine
endlösung der sprache immer weiter im
gange
und da frage ich mich was ist das ende
der fahnenstange was kommt als nächstes
was ist noch möglich wir sind doch schon
ende
und wer uns als faschisten und nazis
bezeichnet diskreditiert und verharmlost
den glücklichen faschismus das will ich
ganz klar sagen
roland möchten sie noch ergänzen ist
alles sagt wolf eine nachfrage jetzt
nicht um was in der afg los ist sondern
welche rezepte hat die afd gegen
rechtsextremismus und ob der wähler da
vielleicht eine kompetenzlücke sieht
weil man nicht so viel darüber hört sie
haben gesagt rechtsextremismus muss man
mit rechtsstaatlichen mitteln bekämpfen
aber das ist ja ein bisschen sag ich mal
sehr generell also wir sind die einzige
partei in deutschland die einzig
demokratische partei wie ich meine die
ezb auch was mitgliedsanträge angeht was
aufnahmen von mitglieder angeht wie ein
ausschlusskriterium hat eine
unvereinbarkeit liste das kenne ich von
anderen parteien nicht also von daher
grenzen wir uns schon von solchen
eventuellen fällen klar und wir haben
auch innerparteilich natürlich gehen wir
diesen dingen immer wieder nach mit
partei aus verfahren die wir einleiten
und auch mit ordnungsmaßnahmen so wie es
in anderen parteien vielleicht auch gang
und gäbe ist auf den
linksextremistischen seite sehe ich dass
ich eher weniger
wenn ich dort einige äußerungen sie also
das tun wir und das forcieren wir auch
weiterhin ganz klar eine letzte
ergänzung herbeiführen das aber gerne
vermeiden wenn sie so viel hier vorne
reden kommen wir nicht mehr zu allen
fragen ich habe noch weitere frage auf
der liste also bitte welche bitten
ganz kurz um das nur auch nochmal
plastisch zu ergänzen
schauen sie auf unsere internetseite afd
de / grundgesetz wo wir eine ganze reihe
von punkten zusammengefasst und
dargestellt haben uns an die
öffentlichkeit zu bringen warum wir uns
besonders dem grundgesetz verpflichtet
fühlen und warum wir und daran arbeiten
wir weiter unser konservativ
bürgerliches profil schärfen um klar zu
machen dass es rote linien zu
rechtsaußen spinnern gibt die bei der
afg nichts zu suchen haben
er kann man hatte ließ der frage eine
frage an die hamburger wahlkämpfer also
ein wolf kümmern die gestiegene
wahlbeteiligung in hamburg ist ja keine
besonderheit von hamburg sondern ist ja
in verschiedenen landtagswahlen der
letzten zeit zu beobachten gewesen
dort hat die ard jeweils von einer
höheren wahlbeteiligung profitiert und
vor allem die ostdeutschen wahlkämpfer
haben sich dies auch dann zu gute
gehalten jetzt ist in hamburg die
wahlbeteiligung ebenfalls gestiegen
die afg hat aber ihre stimmenzahl des
hatten sich vorher noch gesagt nicht
erhöhen können wie erklären sie sich das
da kann man sich dann noch das
wiederholen was ich gerade gesagt habe
wir hatten auch eine massive
mobilisierung von erstwählern so eine
kampagne wie es ja jetzt gegeben hat
auch an den schulen jahres in 2015 so
nicht gegeben
und überall taucht geräte auf überall
sind die grünen dabei die geräte
sozusagen okkupiert haben wir hatten ja
noch am freitag in hamburg eine
demonstration eine kundgebung von über
20.000 greta fans am ende marschierte
wieder die antifa mit und grölte wieder
afd feindliche parolen
wir haben sehr viele nichtwähler auch an
die wahlurne
bracht aber angesichts der höheren
mobilisierung des rot grünen lagers
sie können ja auch die müssen ja auch
sehen dass sie bei in hamburg zwei
bürgermeister einen
bürgermeisterstellvertreterin hatten die
sozusagen alles andere zwischen sich
aufgerieben haben und die
wahlbeteiligung ist auch deswegen
gestiegen weil man in hamburg eine grüne
bürgermeisterin verhindern wollte die
spd hat es geschafft ihr potenzial zu
mobilisieren und gleichzeitig auch noch
bürgerliches potenzial abzuziehen von
aus dem bereich der ehemaligen
nichtwähler und das ist uns halt alles
nicht zugute gekommen
und auch die tatsache dass eben diese
ereignisse die wir ja schon mehrfach
thematisiert haben also thüringen also
auch hanau dass dieses bis zum schluss
in hamburg in form einer gewaltigen
kampagne verarbeitet worden ist gegen
die afd
das hat dieses mal dazu geführt dass der
erhöhte wähleranteil eben nicht zu
unserem vorteil gereichte aber wir
werden daraus auch unsere lehren und
unsere schlussfolgerung ziehen
und ich kann ihnen nur noch mal ja das
habe ich gestern häufiger auch erwähnt
ja ich kann ihnen sagen die deutsche
sprache ist eine sehr reichhaltige und
vielfältige sprache sehr angenehme
sprach ich kann ganz vieles mit ihr
ausdrücken
ich muss nicht immer die
holzhammer-methode nehmen sondern wir
werden auch in zukunft die themen die
eigentliche unser kerngebiet sind auch
den bereich der inneren sicherheit auch
den bereich der zuwanderung gehen werden
wir natürlich nach wie vor bedienen mit
einer klaren und deutlichen sprache aber
eben nicht die hammer auf amboss das
haben wir in hamburg eigentlich auch
weniger gepflegt das liegt auch daran
dass wir mit gesetzen argumentieren wir
sagen ausreisepflichtige sind
abzuschieben das steht so im gesetz in
der verfassung wer das nicht will
der lehnt unsere gesetze ab sagen auch
dass wir als deutsche das recht haben zu
kontrollieren dann nach deutschland
kommt und wer das nicht will der leben
unsere verfassung ab und das sind reine
sache
argumente und daraus kann man uns ja
nicht den strick drehen wir würden nie
jemanden verletzen
und wenn wir darauf aufmerksam machen
dass der senat in hamburg 5,3 milliarden
euro in den vergangenen fünf jahren für
die integration und aufnahme von
ausländern oder von zuwanderern
migranten ausgegeben hat dann ist es ja
keine verletzung der bevölkerung es geht
eben nicht um die leute die da
untergebracht sind
es geht um die falsche politik des
senats man hat genug leerstehende
kaserne gehabt da hätte man auch
unterbringen können nein man sollte das
nicht man hat neubausiedlung gebaut in
naturschutzgebiete und wir lassen uns
das recht einfach nicht nehmen und uns
in diesem recht nicht einschränken
fakten deutlich zu benennen ohne jetzt
sagen wir wir kommentieren natürlich
aber wir polemisieren nicht in dem
bereich und das ist auch eine der der
zukünftigen verfahrensweisen die wir für
uns in übereinstimmung auch mit dem
landesvorstand in hamburg so beschlossen
haben und das wird es auch in hamburg
allgemeines einvernehmen geben also
weiterhin deutliche sprache
aber jedenfalls nicht etwas wo unsere
politischen gegner etwas gegen uns
instrumentalisieren können und ich denke
dass unser verdammt gutes demokratisches
recht
dann hat die nächste frage herr jordaans
eine frage an die zwei vertreter aus
hamburg habe ich sie richtig verstanden
dass sie sagen dass die taktik der
ausgrenzung der afd durch durch andere
parteien und durch die zivilgesellschaft
aufgegangen ist erich und zweite frage
an herrn papa weil gerade auch von eine
frage zur kompetenz stücken gestellt
wurde die einzige partei die ja in
hamburg wirklich zugelegt hat waren die
grünen die wie man kann sich ihre partei
sich weist ein entgegengesetztes
wissenschaftlichen mainstreams beim
thema klima zu positionieren
also wir hatten ja erstmal ausgrenzung
angesprochen erstmal ausgrenzung
ich denke mal eine eine form der
ausgrenzung wie wir sie erlebt haben
die ist für die demokratie nicht
förderlich könnte auch sagen sie ist
einfach für die demokratie schädlich
oder
endlich es kann doch nicht sein dass man
bürger davon abhält sich mit uns zu
unterhalten weil man angst hat dass wir
die bürger dann doch noch überzeugen in
der persönlichen diskussion
und wenn sie sagen zivilgesellschaft ob
die die aktivität der
zivilgesellschaften erfolg gehabt hat
ich glaube da kann man in der welt
erschienen ja kürzlich ein artikel
zivilgesellschaft und ihre
schlägertruppen war das überschrieben
und wenn ich mir dann überlege was die
zivilgesellschaft alles mobilisiert hat
in hamburg das waren nicht nur zulässige
verfahren das waren keine keine ich sag
mal sachlichen auseinandersetzung in der
scholz hat mal gesagt in hamburg man
muss sich mit der afg auseinandersetzt
man muss sie inhaltlich stellen
es hat nun versuche gegeben in hamburg
sich mit uns inhaltlich
auseinanderzusetzen oder uns inhaltlich
zu stellen es gibt immer nur diese
brutale verlorene rische ausgrenzungen
abgrenzung und wenn man die antifa
weiterhin gewähren lässt also bei mir
sie zum wiederholten mal vier mit sekt
mit mit farbe gefüllte sektflaschen
durch die scheiben gegangen ja
kinderzimmerfenster von anderen familien
nebenan
und wenn man das nicht wirklich
anprangert und ich denke da sind auch
schuldig dass ich das so deutlich sagen
die medien in der pflicht wenn man das
nicht macht und diese aktivitäten duldet
und darüber hinaus noch die antifa
halbstaatlich mit mit zuwendungen
fördert dann ist in diesem gesellschaft
wirklich etwas faul 23 punkte anknüpfen
daran erstens scholz damals noch spd
erste bürgermeistern haben wo ich hatte
mal in einem papier da wurde allseits
recht viel augenmerk darauf gerichtet
aufgefordert man müsse mit der afg
diskutieren man müsse ihre argumente
analysieren und ernst nehmen und sich
damit auseinandersetzen
davon ist herzlich wenig übriggeblieben
punkt 1.2 zivilgesellschaft
zivilgesellschaft ist eben auch und
gerade diese antifa die
mehrere gruppierungen vom hamburger
verfassungsschutz beobachtet werden und
die gleichzeitig in einer art und weise
als teil der zivilgesellschaft von
rot-grün auch mit umarmt werden was den
hamburgischen vs chef kürzlich dazu
führte zu sagen achtung die gefahr ist
gestiegen es gibt nicht mehr nur gewalt
von links gegen sachen es ist jetzt auch
eine gefährdung von personen ernsthaft
in die nähe gerückt und er müsse davor
warnen das als thema zivilgesellschaft
antifa und ausgrenzung diese art und
weise der stigmatisierung des trainings
legitime bis hinein in die hamburgische
bürgerschaft wo ein spd-vertreter
kürzlich den alten linksradikalen
kampfruf brachte faschismus ist keine
meinung faschismus ist ein verbrechen
und dazu gehört dann satz eins noch dazu
alles was konservativ ist familie
tradition heimat vaterland sei dann
faschistisch und gehöre letztlich die
meinungsfreiheit der meinungsfreiheit
nicht mehr sondern müsse verboten werden
das ist die verschärfung des klimas die
einer demokratischen rechtsstaatlichen
freiheitlichen gesellschaft an sich
unwürdig ist
zweite frage möchte ich aber ganz kurz
noch mal zur ersten kommt was
zivilgesellschaft insgesamt an dieses
wort was ich immer sehr merkwürdig
finden wie es auch in diesen
sprachgebrauch immer wieder benutzt wird
was meinen sie denn konkret mit der
zivilgesellschaft
ich fühle mich der zivilgesellschaft
genauso angehörig genauso wie unsere
abgeordneten in den parlamenten die
kommen alle aus der mitte der
gesellschaft wir haben alle im
größtenteils berufe erlernt sind
gestandene leute in handwerksmeister ich
gehöre mit servo zur zivilgesellschaft
ich leiste meinen beitrag für diese
gesellschaft ohne staatliche
subventionen ist wirklich ganz klar
sagen ich fühle mich da vorher zugehörig
also diese schönen schon alleine diese
wortwahl und ausgrenzung personengruppen
als zivilgesellschaft zu bezeichnen die
anderen gehören nicht dazu
finde ich schon unzulässig zur zweiten
frage was die klimadebatte angeht
niemand bei uns in der afg mit den
klimawandel
das will ich ja mal ganz klar
wir erarbeiten konzepte wie wir mit
diesen umgehen wir haben sicherlich eine
ganz andere herangehensweise als die
etablierten parteien zu diesem thema wir
stehen zu umwelt und naturschutz ganz
klar das sind für uns wichtige themen
wir stehen an der seite der landwirte
was für uns ein großes thema und großes
problem ist was wir gerade im ländlichen
raum sehen wie dort eine ländliche
region verwöhnt weil kleine bauern hilfe
immer mehr schließen müssen das sind für
uns themen die wir in der programmatik
aufarbeiten und an die wir herangehen
und ich denke damit haben wir auch ein
großes wählerpotenzial was wir weiterhin
natürlich erschließen wollen die nächste
frage hat die kollegen auf der von uns
aus gesehen rechten seite morgen
christine dankbar berliner zeitung
eine frage an herrn bauland sie haben
vorhin gesagt wir müssen alle ein
bisschen mehr abrüsten wo sehen sie den
fehler bei sich
sie wissen dass wir ein
parteiausschlussverfahren haben dass es
auch bei uns menschen gibt die sich
anders benehmen als das einer
demokratischen partei seien sollte sie
kennen diese ausschlussverfahren sie
wissen auch wie schwierig das ist
weil das parteiengesetz halt solche
möglichkeiten nicht so einfach eröffnet
aber was ich bin mit abrüstung gemeint
habe bezieht sich genau wie er kuba das
gesagt hat inzwischen auch auf die
anderen die konkurrenten und ich sage
auch ganz offen auf die medien
denn ich betone das noch mal was sich in
den letzten tagen in einem deutschen
leitmedium als kommentar eines
herausgebers gelesen habe hätte ich in
der bundesrepublik nicht für möglich
gehalten
wenn da keine abrüstung geschieht ich
wüsste nicht wie man wie ich nach diesen
kommentar mit demjenigen den ich sogar
persönlich kenne noch reden könnte wenn
da nicht abgerüstet wird
dann weiß ich auch nicht wie das mit der
demokratie diesem lande weiter gehen
das gilt natürlich auch für uns auch wir
haben uns manchmal in der wortwahl
vergriffen
das wissen sie ja mein vogel schoss war
ein fehler
dafür habe ich mich inzwischen 20 mal
entschuldigt das wird kaum zur kenntnis
genommen doch es gibt journalisten die
das zur kenntnis nehmen ich will das
offen sagen aber wenn ich dann manche
kommentare lesen muss dann habe ich das
gefühl da gibt es gar kein gespräch mehr
sondern wir werden in einer richtung
verortet die mit demokratie nichts mehr
zu tun hat und ehrlich gesagt ich habe
noch ich bin ja nur noch etwas älter als
ackermann ich habe also noch erlebt die
erste auseinandersetzung
manchmal denke ich
damals hat es für die sogenannten
unterstützer der hf die am anfang die
idee hatten dass das was
gesellschaftlich wichtiges ist sozusagen
für den fortschritt gab es in den medien
na sagen wir mehr differenzierte
kommentare als heute über uns es ist
leider so und wenn das meine ich auch
mit abrüstung wenn wir da nicht abrüsten
weiß ich auch nicht mehr wie ein
gespräch zwischen uns möglich sein soll
wenn ich als mensch und als politiker so
verdammt werde wie das in einigen medien
geschieht dann kann ich auch nicht mehr
reden was soll ich mit demjenigen noch
reden und das ist mit abrüstung gemeint
ich habe nicht das jahr für das soweit
die pressekonferenz der afg nach der
wahl in hamburg wie schon vermutet am
anfang ging es ja weniger um die wahl in
hamburg und erklärungen warum es für die
afg nur für 5,3 prozent gereicht hat in
der neuen bürgerschaft sondern in erster
linie um das selbstverständnis der afg
insgesamt im land um die einflüsse von
thüringen um das was in hanau passiert
ist und was auf
die afg immer wieder zurückfällt die
nokia ich wiederhole noch mal zu einem
priester beklagt dass es noch den
politischen gegner warum oder gefragt
warum es den politischen gegner so
leicht gelingt die tat in hanau immer
wieder mit der afc in verbindung zu
bringen und das ist hat er mit seinen
äußerungen auch noch mal hier bestätigt
das ist ganz offensichtlich auch ein
appell an die eigene partei ist und
weniger einen angriff auf den
politischen gegner darüber nachzudenken
wie man damit in zukunft umgeht das hat
man hier immer wieder beteuert dass man
nicht der rechtsextremistisch und
rassistisch sei
wie gesagt das ist jetzt eine äußerung
der afd
an den taten und worten muss man sie
messen auch wenn die
fraktionsvorsitzende der afg alles
weiter im bundestag zum beispiel von
kopftuchmädchen und alimentierten messer
männern spricht dann ist das sind da
sicherlich äußerungen die durch diese
beteuerungen und diese erklärungen hier
in der bundespressekonferenz nicht
gedeckt sind das war die pressekonferenz
der asd um 12 uhr 30 geht es hier weiter
mit der pressekonferenz der linken zur
wahl in hamburg aber da spielt zum
beispiel thüringen auch sicherlich eine
große rolle wie es dort weitergeht da
ist die partei der linken ja unmittelbar
beteiligt und die beiden
bundesvorsitzenden katja kipping und
bernd riexinger werde man auch hier
seien beim riexinger hoffentlich danach
noch im phoenix-interview soweit jetzt
erst mal aus berlin zurück nach bonn